and if i could erase any of the stupid
things that i've done in life
that's probably it they didn't want it
shown do you think you owe me an apology
absolutely part one of the first ever
keeping up with the kardashians reunion
special just
aired and the famous family is spilling
all the tea
tune in because you never know what's
gonna happen now we're breaking down the
seven biggest bombshell revelations
starting with this i try not to have any
regrets
but it's probably the one thing that i
wish didn't exist kim kardashian opens
up about that sex tape with her ex
ray j noting that she hasn't had to
explain it to her kids
yet but knows that one day she might
luckily i think that so many years have
gone on and so many things have happened
positively that it really erases that
that is something that i have to live
with for the rest of my life that is
something that's like
being held over my head and if i could
erase any of the stupid things that i've
done in life
that's probably it and it's more so from
being a mom
than anything another thing kim wishes
she could erase
her big fight with courtney don't ever
come at me like that don't i swear to
god i'll punch you in your face
while the brawl made for great tv kim
and courtney didn't want their fight to
play out on the show
but unfortunately for them the sisters
got into it on the wrong day
one day out of all of filming we have an
e-representative come to set
and that day an e representative was on
set kendall and i were just kind of in
shock
i thought it was a joke they were joking
at first and so they didn't want it
shown but also an e-rep is there and
it's like and they know it happens
they know what happened right and while
the big kardashian fight
was featured on keeping up kylie
jenner's relationship with on
off boyfriend travis scott was not and
she dishes on keeping their love
off camera i don't know i guess he just
sometimes he didn't want to be filmed i
never pressured him to be on the show
of course kylie and the rapper share a
three-year-old daughter stormy
and when asked if marriage is in their
future she played coy
i'm not thinking about marriage right
now but
i would hope to get married one day the
kylie cosmetics founder also opened up
about keeping her pregnancy private
i shared so much of my life i was also
really young when i got pregnant
and it was just a lot for me personally
i didn't know how i would bring that to
the public
too and have you know everyone's
opinions i think it was just something
that i needed to go through
by myself so i just decided to not even
deal with that coming in at number four
on our list the chris humphries of it
all
that i don't know kim tied the knot with
the basketball player in a 2011
televised multi-million dollar wedding
but 72 days later
they called it quits now kris jenner
admits that she tried to get her
daughter out of the relationship
right before kim said i do it was the
night before was the her rehearsal
yeah and i just went upstairs and i said
can i talk to you and she said sure and
i said listen
if you really don't want to do this i
don't think you should do it
i think this could be a really bad idea
what you said want to get out of it
go i'm going to put you in a car no one
will find you just
leave and and i'll take care of it well
kim went through with the wedding but
says it didn't take long
for her to realize she made a mistake we
get to italy for a honeymoon
and i was like i think i made the wrong
decision
wow and then i went to new york and i
was miserable the kkw beauty founder
admits she handled the breakup
in the worst way and said she absolutely
owed her ex
an apology in fact kim says she tried
calling chris for months but later ran
into him at a hotel when she was
pregnant with her son
saint he just literally looked at me and
like wouldn't even
speak to me wow he's very faith-based
and so
i'm sure he would have loved to not have
a marriage on his record
of course kim went on to marry kanye
west in 2014
and the two share four children together
he's just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart
the reality star filed for divorce from
the rapper in february but when it comes
to the reason for their split
she's staying tight-lipped i honestly
don't think i would even
say it here on tv but it was not like
one specific thing that happened on
either part i think it was just a
general
difference of opinions on a few things
that led to this decision
but kim says there's nothing but love
between them
kanye will always be family we have an
amazing co-parenting relationship
and i i respect him so much and i think
we
i think we'll have you know that was my
friend first
first and foremost for a long time so i
i can't see that going away
i will forever be kanye's biggest fan
and when it comes to dating the 40 year
old reveals what she's looking for
next i think what i was looking for and
who i was
you know years ago is completely
different than who i am today and i
value privacy
and i just want something that's like
really real
but before kanye before chris humphries
before keeping up
and before kim was a celebrity in her
own right kim was besties with and a
stylist for
paris hilton and while the two had a
falling out
kim opens up about how they rekindled
their friendship
she did that interview about like
something that was negative to me and
called my butt fat or like something
gross or something i don't know right
cottage cheese in the trash bag we spoke
afterwards
and had a real like mature conversation
about that and then i think you know
we drifted for a while but
we're super back cool and i think that
you know my words um i think that
you know i have a lot of respect i will
never ever think that i'm like
too good or to to not know where you
know i came from
and we have like a really good
relationship now and last but not least
chris opens up about her marriage to
caitlyn jenner saying that she did not
know her ex was planning to transition
when they split
but says they probably would have broken
up even if caitlyn hadn't transitioned
what was meant to be out of that
relationship was kendall and kylie
so without that i wouldn't have
one-sixth and one-sixth of my heart
sitting here and that i'm so grateful
for and feel like it was such a blessing
part two of the keeping up with the
kardashians reunion special
airs sunday june 20th on e
you